EMILY: He basically just
said five minute
presentation on the topic.
And then the day we were
doing it, he was like,
this is very important.
This is serious stuff.
And we're like, oh.
Oops.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
GUEST SPEAKER: Science isn't
just about doing experiments.
The students have to learn
to talk about them too.
Why?
Because one day, any one
of them might win this.
JOHN DOLHUN: You will be giving
oral presentations in
this course.
And they start next Friday.
Seven of you will be
going next Friday.
And seven of you will be going
the following week.
So you'll be preparing a five
minute oral delivery on some
aspect that we'll
assign to you.
GUEST SPEAKER: Let's see how
the first group does.
JOHN DOLHUN: Now today we're
going to go through seven of
your presentations.
This is serious business.
You get scored for this.
EMILY: My topic was solvent
choices and techniques for
single crystal determination.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
FRED: It's like a mathematical
puzzle.
Any questions?
JOHN DOLHUN: Could you show
us your spectrum and your
interpretation of the peaks?
JASON: Dr. Dolhun was very
disappointed in a lot of
people's presentations.
People would conclude, and then
they would ask if there
are any questions.
And Dr. Dolhun would be the
first one on there.
He's like, yeah.
And he spits out the question he
gave them in the beginning.
JOHN DOLHUN: Your topic
was solvent choices.
Your topic was vacuum
distillation problems.
So can you draw a grid
on the board?
It came out as crystals.
How much of those solutions
did you use?
So could you tell us some
of the problems?
You have all those.
Show us which solvents you
actually went through.
EMILY: Um.
FRED: Um.
JASON: Um.
DAN: Um.
ROO-RA: Um.
PAUL: Um.
IKE: I'm sorry.
I thought I was supposed
to do the NMR.
GUEST SPEAKER: What happened?
EMILY: Professor Dolhun didn't
tell us beforehand to focus
more on our results from
our experiments.
So he was disappointed.
FRED: I wasn't too sure what
the instructions were.
So now that I know that he
wanted us to analyze our own
data, I definitely would have
done that a lot more.
It was mostly improvised.
I didn't prepare that much
because I was out with friends
last night.
PAUL: I did everything right.
It just wasn't a great
presentation.
ANTHONY: I'm glad I didn't go
today, because it was nice to
see what he wanted.
I guess there was
some confusion.
But now I know exactly
what he wants.
So I can give it to
him next week.
PHIL: It was clear who put time
into the talk and clear
who didn't.
EMILY: Next week the people
going will do a lot better.
GUEST SPEAKER: Emily's right.
They do.
And Dr. Dolhun is impressed.
The students really
turned it around.
JOHN DOLHUN: So these were
actually very, very good.
Very well done.
I'm very, very happy.
JASON: I didn't do so well.
Oh my gosh, did I
talk too fast?
I need to take a public
speaking class next.
JULIE: I did say that, yeah.
[MUSIC PLAYING]